[Musique]
eh bien, je veux dire que le changement climatique va
avoir son propre ensemble de défis, certains
problèmes que
nous allons vous résoudre
qui
vous poussent à déplacer votre fleur et votre fenêtre plus tôt
dans l'année et si vous pouvez le faire, vous
pourrez peut-être en éviter certains  de cette
perte de chaleur pendant les deux premières euh
quelques semaines de floraison
[Musique]
nous pouvons essayer de planter des variétés qui
pourraient être plus tolérantes à la chaleur mais
il n'y a pas grand-chose que nous puissions faire une fois qu'elles sont en
culture elles ont besoin de temps frais  et
a besoin d'humidité, ce sont vraiment les
meilleures choses que nous puissions faire pour la
récolte de canola
à la rangée d'arbres,
nous avons collecté un germoplasme mondial
Source sources de toutes sortes de variétés
de canola et d'espèces apparentées et nous
les cultivons dans des essais en tête-à-tête
et nous recherchons les types de
variations
que nous pouvons  démontrer et alors que nous en
trouverons qui sont plus tolérants, nous
les croiserons
pour créer une nouvelle population et la soumettre
au même type de stress et
faire avancer ce matériel
[Musique]
merci